we have had a couple near stitches
situations
Kristen Bell showing off a gnarly battle
wound one of the many job hazards when
you're a mom of two they're exploring
their own way of being goofy or telling
jokes and it's impressive yeah we're
impressed by the damage left by Delta
Kristen and hubby Dax Shepard's youngest
daughter we are really good at splitting
all the baby responsibilities 50 50.
except for the having it and creating it
that was me over on the gram the proud
mom puts her minor Jiu Jitsu injury on
full display saying she took some teeth
to the nose we'll recover you should see
the other guy the other guy meaning her
eight-year-old who Christian jokes has
big sharp buck teeth those good
experiences that you want are out there
we also know that martial arts have
become a mother-daughter hobby with
Kristen sharing in February that their
Jiu Jitsu classes have brought them
closer together and it's kind of
phenomenal I want my kids to have an
activated sense of self when they walk
out the door of our house Kristen has
shown off plenty of those phenomenal
moments on social media while keeping
Delta and nine-year-old sister Lincoln's
faces hidden something she and hubby Dax
Shepard agreed on together in a marriage
and when you're raising kids there's so
much compromise because he wants to
parent one way I want a parent one way
but when we have a shared goal that just
makes us feel more connected also you
really come to rely on each other in a
way that reminds you like oh right I
have this amazing human in my life
Kristen and Dax who celebrate 10 years
of marriage in October definitely have
their hands full with the two little
ones when you come out and you're in
sequence all doubt up ready for your big
night what do the girls say well they
usually want to play with the dress
because it's like not I at all the Vibes
I usually give off at home but I did get
four different voice memos on my phone
on the way here about the fact that we
didn't have Oreos and they'd been
counting on Oreos and then what a huge
disappointment I was because I had not
restocked the Oreos please blame them
it's a good cookie well no word yet if
there was an Oreo shortage before Jiu
Jitsu class but as they say loves the
battlefield I like love having my kids
but they're not
foreign